[Musique]
et
leur caisse métropolitain de montréal
amorce dès demain une tournée aux états
unis quatre concerts dans quatre villes
on en parle tout de suite avec le
directeur artistique le chef d'orchestre
à vie pour leur caisse métropolitain
yannick nézet-séguin bonjour bonjour
grand plaisir de vous parler de vrai
dire l'infatigable nézet-séguin le
concert ce soir maison symphonique de
montréal puis ensuite bien première
tournée aux états unis pour l'heure
quatre absolument on est tous évidemment
très fébrile mais tous très confiants
aussi au nord envie d'aller de
recommencer ça après notre tournée
européenne 10 à 2 1 on envie de
recommencer ça aux etats-unis et 2 de
montrer ce qu'on sait faire et on espère
récolter le même succès mais voilà ça va
être votre deuxième tournée
internationale après la tournée
européenne qu'est ce que ça apporte un
orchestre emprunté un circuit
international
mais évidemment les tournées d'abord
c'est pourtant ce que ça apporte alors
qu'est ce c'est plutôt ce qu'on essaie
d'apporter au public c'est à dire que
c'est
c'est un circuit où les orques et se
déplacent à travers le monde quand ils
ont un certain niveau de façon à montrer
représenter chacun chaque
caractéristique surtout du pays ou
labello ou deux dans le cas de la
province de laquelle on vient montrer un
peu j'ai la personnalité des des
musiciens dont le bagage l'histoire et
en retour c'est sûr que ça apporte
beaucoup aux musiciens de leur caisse
puis auchel frau sens où on peut de
jouer dans des salles différentes
on se colle à des publics différents ça
nous fait grandir parce qu'on répète
aussi le même programme dans plusieurs
contextes différents dans un laps de
temps assez l'approché donc c'est une
situation c'est lourd
en fait de voyager avec tout d'abord
qu'est-ce qui suis 100 personnes
mais ça vaut la peine c'est c'est
vraiment une solution gagnante pour tout
le monde et donc vraiment une belle
expérience est ce que vous sentez que
vos musiciens on a un peu le trac avant
de partir aux etats unis c'est sûr c'est
sûr il ya des salles mythiques dans
lesquels on va aller par ex
prasad du de leur caisse de chicago les
gens qui qui joue ne les membres de nos
sections de cuivres ont admis et reset
hors caisse depuis longtemps donc
d'aller jouer dans la salle de cet
orgueil c'est très impressionnant
elle est jouée accord legear a
évidemment c'est une des deux ou trois
plus grandes salles du monde avec une
histoire incroyable donc moi je dirige
et à change de devises assez
régulièrement à canet guillaume marquet
de philadephie lors que si tu mettras
parle de la prime est d'arriver avec les
gèlent leurs questions trop polis des
c'est sûr que c'est un rêve exaucé pour
beaucoup des musiciens mais tout comme
on a fait en europe
je pense qu'on aviv l'ofppt l'est de
confiance et surtout sachant qu'on ne
voie différente à porter je convaincu
que le public va tomber amoureux du
métropolitain mais connaît en fait on
dit souvent que la musique classique ces
réserves est vraiment aux élites on
connaît votre signature de vouloir
vraiment démocratiser tout ça la musique
orchestrale de l'amener aux gens est ce
que vous vous avez choisi d'offrir c'est
une oeuvre la quatrième symphonie de
bruckner une oeuvre que vous tenez
absolument à présent plus pourquoi c'est
peu voilà pourquoi en fait parce que
c'est une oeuvre qui représente très
bien le travail que j'ai fait avec les
sièges métropolitaine puisque sur atma
classique ont enregistré son période
d'une dizaine d'années toutes les
symphonies de bruckner donc cessé comme
indissociable de notre histoire commune
et c'est une oeuvre dans laquelle j'ai
pression justement que la sonorité
raffiné la sonorité sensible très plein
d' écoute mutuelle de leurs questions et
de politesse pour pouvoir s'épanouir
puis mais vous parlez d'accessibilité
c'est sûr que brou clair c'est pas a
priori le compositeur qu'on associe de
plus à une écoute facile mais justement
quand les gens font confiance
est ce qu'on peut leur apporter je pense
que ça va peut-être gagner des nouveaux
fans
le broker durant la tournée puis non
seulement on a d'autres atouts si on ne
la maison
un autre juriste didonato quick est une
des plus grandes chanteuses du moment
qui est une amie à moi et on collabore
régulièrement on s'est connu d'ailleurs
il ya des années que lui disant à
montréal donc ça va être les belles
retrouvailles et aussi au cours de la
tournée on a organisé quand même
quelques activités éducatives dans les
différentes villes
on va aller dans une école secondaire à
chicago on va aller dire et lucien mois
dans une école primaire à new york
on va aussi faire un pelé de
philadelphie donc les membres de leur
caisse de philadelphie les membres du
métropolitain avec des membres la
communauté qu'il advient des musiciens
amateurs des étudiants des retraités on
va tous se retrouver sur une scène donc
ya pas que les concerts en salle qui ont
été organisées et ça je trouve que ça
fait vraiment c'est vraiment la
signature om et comment vous faites pour
conjuguer tous à être établies comme ça
à philadelphie chef d'orchestre de
l'orchestré métropolitain de montréal
mais également à new york
plus récemment au m comment vous faites
pour faire tout ça c'est c'est sûr que
le mot horaires et gestion c'est très
important
mais bon j'ai des gens qui s'occupent de
ça pour moi quand même mon agent c'est
du sommet le plus important là dedans
c'est que je trouve mon bonheur à avoir
trois institutions qui sont très
complémentaires et avec lesquels j'ai
une histoire plus ou moins anciennes et
récentes métropolitaine depuis 20 ans
lemaitre seulement depuis deux ans puis
philadelphie depuis huit ans donc j'ai
l'impression que mes histoires
personnelles avec chacune des
institutions et aussi leur leur place
dans le l'échiquier mondial de la
musique classique est très différente
donc ça mais doit redevenir le meilleur
artiste je sais prendre des idées de
chacune des institutions et les amener à
ma façon
dans l'autre institution puis j'ai
disons que je vois pas nier que si
occupés comme vie mais j'ai l'impression
de me sentir maintenant dans trois
familles et ça ça me fait beaucoup de
bien au lieu de voyager avec beaucoup de
d'apparitions en tant qu'invité donc ça
disons je suis très heureux jusqu'à
maintenant
dubois mais je suis très très heureux en
tout cas vous êtes tout un ambassadeur
en temps pour la musique classique que
pour le pays et le canada que vous
représentez dans tous peuvent
fonctionner que les et ses gains merci
d'avoir été avec nous puis bonne tournée
américaine avec leur caisse
métropolitaine en riant
c'est très gentil on va vous portez avec
nous dans nos bagages merci aux plaisirs